bonsoir et bienvenue en kiosque votre
émission culturale alors au menu ce soir
la compagnie à gare de fou de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sera en
représentation le samedi 17 janvier à la
salle de la tour à voisins pour
présenter un spectacle autour des textes
d'une Berteau Eco les Pokémon crew était
à la Merise de Trappes la compagnie de
hip-hop a présenté silence on tourne
nous les avons rencontrés et puis autre
rencontre avec Sylvain Maurice metteur
en scène des sorcières c'est le 24
janvier à la Meurice de Trappes voilà ce
que l'on peut découvrir dans ce nouveau
numéro place maintenant au théâtre
la compagnie garde-fou de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux sera sur la scène
de la salle de la tour de voisins
bretonneuse samedi 17 janvier à partir
de 21h pour leur spectacle comment nous
avons les réponses je sais pas si je le
dis bienvenue
ah voilà quand tout simplement deux
actrices sur scène donc l'ordre et vous
et Lisa vigor cette pièce que vous jouez
samedi vous la jouer déjà depuis deux
ans c'est une pièce qui est tirée de
textes d'Humberto Eco comment prendre
l'avion avec un saumon qui sont des
modes d'emploi en fait des modes
d'emploi d'Umberto Eco sur la vie
quotidienne les tous les comments qu'on
peut se poser plus ou moins farfelus
quand même justement tous ces comment on
va parler tous les comments mais tel que
nous ce qu'on a ce qu'on aborde qu'une
mince partie de tous les commandes qu'il
aborde dans son livre on a pris on en
prend qu'une dizaine il y a par exemple
comment ne pas utiliser le téléphone
portable comment reconnaître un film
porno ça c'est pas possible
justement
il explique comment on peut s'en passer
en quelle catégorie on est de personnes
quand les utilisent commentent pas
parler de foot comment éviter les
maladies contagieuses comment ne pas
dire absolument voilà c'est très très
large donc absolument comment ne pas
dire absolument pourquoi
Umberto est cour parce que c'est pas un
auteur de pièce de théâtre non c'est pas
du tout un auteur un auteur de théâtre
ce qui s'est passé c'est que quand on a
voulu monter ce spectacle ensemble on a
d'abord voulu monter avec l'or
créer des personnages en fait donc on a
créé des personnages qui sont
Marie-Agnès qui ne chercheuse en CNRS et
prune son assistante et on avait une
envie toutes les deux de voilà de faire
un spectacle
qui traite du quotidien mais comment
notre quotidien peut nous bouffer
pardonne-moi l'expression
et comment voilà nous nous pourrit la
vie tout simplement
donc voilà on a cherché des textes
et quand on a découvert les textes
Umberto Eco c'est tombé comme une
évidence c'est pile pour absolument ça
c'est absolument ça
c'est le moment ça va être le mot mais
comment on adapte alors du coup des des
textes écrits pour le théâtre alors du
coup alors on rajoute du jeu faut rendre
oral un texte qui ne l'est pas donc ça
c'est une Traille de mise en bouche
énormément
c'est prendre conscience des mots les
dire mais ça c'est un travail de
comédien en fait au final à la base moi
je suis passionnée par les textes non
théâtraux donc un peu de pratique
derrière
puis bah en fait comme de toute façon il
y avait déjà du théâtre de fée vu qu'il
y avait ces deux personnages là qui
étaient construits
ensemble voilà il a fallu penser à cette
idée de de conférence qu'on invite les
gens à venir à une conférence réelle
et donc de le jeu est venu de lui-même
en fait car ces textes ne sont que des
textes de la conférence en fait cette
conférence Est et là pour nous expliquer
de donner des réponses sur tous ces
communs donc on a pris tel quel au final
ces textes après il y a du jeu qui vient
au fur et à mesure entre nos personnages
entre les textes pendant les textes et
ça c'est
pas trop pour dire pardon mais
c'est vraiment les textes qui
amènent les réactions de nos personnages
donc voilà c'est autant les textes
Umberto Eco que de l'improvisation entre
nos deux personnages combien de textes
vous présentez mercredi alors je les ai
plus en tête car il y a quelques petits
remaniement dernièrement elle a été
jouée de maintes fois ouais elle a été
joué sur la saison 22e dimanche samedi
soir
je crois qu'on en a un peu plus d'une
dizaine voilà un peu plus
extrait comme ça absolument ça me
donnera un avis donc de ce fameux pièces
comment nous avons les réponses
comment manger en avion parmi les
nourritures salissantes on a les
spaghettis bolognaise le goulash
gratiné appelle sortie du four ou le
consommer bouillant servi dans une tasse
sans en
un endroit chocolat cendre à la gauche
de son épaule gauche nécessite un
ensemble d'opérations complexes entre
autres détourner le regard de la route
et puis roulent à 180 km heure se servir
du cendrier en ayant une seconde
distraire le péché de sodomie avec un
camion
les auteurs de ces notices menteuses ont
appris depuis leur plus tendre enfance
que lorsque l'on doit dire quelque chose
il faut dire tout ce que l'on sait et
rien que ce que l'on sait ni plus si
loin donc c'est pourquoi à la rubrique
souvent allergie à l'un des composants
du produit alors en d'autres termes cela
veut dire que si vous prenez ce
médicament et qu'aussitôt après vous
vous écroulez à terre avec de la pâte
verte à la bouche et maintenant c'est
pas le grand plat
voilà c'est très très drôle il y a
beaucoup de jeux de de visage de jeux
d'expression en fait toute cette
conférence a été bâtie dans une idée
qu'on illustre pour faire comprendre au
public ce qu'on est en train de raconter
donc il y a tout un jeu de mine qui est
extrêmement important mais ça c'est la
façon dont nos deux personnages vont
conçu leur conférence c'est il y a
beaucoup de mises en abîme on s'est
beaucoup pris la tête
justement comme c'était pas une pièce de
théâtre comment on allait en faire un
spectacle de théâtre mais comment
justement vous arrivez à travailler
toutes les deux comme ça c'est une vraie
harmonie
s'enchaînent
vous allez me dire ça fait 22 fois qu'on
joue cette pièce donc ça y est on est
rodé mais quand même il y a c'est sur
travail
il y a une très très grande complicité
entre leur et moi en tant que comédienne
et ça c'est une des choses qui ressort
énormément pour les personnes qui
viennent me voir ça nous fait plaisir
d'ailleurs c'est notre complicité de jeu
on se connaît depuis un peu plus de 10
ans maintenant parce qu'on peut raconter
je suis je professeur à la compagnie
garde-fou et l'orge je l'ai connu elle
avait 12 ans c'était mon élève donc
maintenant elle est comédienne
professionnelle elle suit des cours des
cours dans des conservateurs
professionnels donc
c'est vrai qu'on se connaît très très
bien et d'autant plus que le rapport
qu'on a créé sur scène
ressemble un tout petit peu à ce qu'on a
vécu dans la vie car je suis son maître
de stage elle est mon assistante et
petit à petit les rôles voilà s'inverse
vous avez dit dans cette pièce il y a de
la place pour l'improvisation énormément
il y a en fait toutes les interactions
qu'on a toutes les deux ne sont pas
écrites
d'accord donc parce que ça coule de
source alors là les extraits qu'on a vu
il y a pas d'improvisation voilà les
textes
Umberto Eco mais voilà ils peuvent
arriver qu'on s'apostrophe l'une l'autre
qu'on réagisse à ce que vient de dire
l'autre sans que ça soit prévu en fait
ça c'est vraiment nos personnages qui en
fonction du mouvement fonction du texte
interagissent chaque soir c'est pas le
même spectacle exactement donc si on l'a
vu il y a un an un voisin abandonné on
peut revenir samedi soir en plus entre
temps ça ça
a vraiment le spectacle est réservé un
public adulte à partir de 16 ans 15 ans
parce qu'il y a des choses
en fait c'est un spectacle est
terriblement cynique donc déjà le cinéma
donc ça quoi déjà très très cynique donc
le message qui passe c'est pas
spécialement très gai
mine de rien nous on l'amène vers
quelque chose qui est très sombre au
final derrière c'est le cynisme nous
fait rire mais c'est pour faire passer
un message qui est derrière qui est
convie dans une société qui nous plaît
pas et c'est ça qui est le plus
important
et on amène des idées
qui pour nous se dirige vers un public
véritablement adulte pour le comprendre
il y a également le texte en lui-même
Umberto Eco c'est très très écrit c'est
très bavard
c'est un langage assez comment dire
alors non justement enfin il y a des
choses crues il y a des choses il y a
quel bon il y a le film comment
reconnaître comment reconnaître un film
porno c'est sûr qu'on va pas dans la
finesse à l'intérieur de ce texte là
mais de façon générale non non c'est
c'est très très écrit
disons faut régulièrement avoir le
dictionnaire en tête quand même c'est
une professeur Umberto Eco
c'est pas de l'oralité c'est pas du
roman de gare il y a ça aussi mine de
rien quand on voit déjà que notre public
adulte des fois dit mais j'ai pas tous
saisi il m'a fallu la deuxième pour
mieux concentrer sur les textes on sait
que voilà quelqu'un de trop jeune je
pense sincèrement que ça serait encore
plus difficile à suivre une pièce pour
réfléchir une pièce aussi pour rire oui
les deux on sourit on dévoile pas tout
mais il y a deux parties dans la pièce
mais le signe
alors c'est vraiment cynique tout du
long tout le monde en prend pour son
grade
mais c'est la magie du cynisme c'est à
dire que ça fait rire énormément mais le
message qui passe derrière le cynisme
c'est honnêtement quelque chose de noir
et de sombre et c'est ça aussi qu'on a
beaucoup aimé c'était pour faire passer
la pilule on fait rire mais faut la
passer la pilule quand même c'est après
coup plutôt c'est vers la fin du
spectacle mais aussi tout à coup
on est content quand des gens nous
disent oui ça ah mais en fait ça fait
réfléchir quand vous dites ça ça nous
rappelle ça
donc voilà c'est un spectacle qui est
pas une comédie qui est on pourrait dire
une comédie satirique mais c'est
vraiment du tas de contemporain en fait
au final alors du théâtre contemporain
une comédie c'est à découvrir donc
samedi à 17 janvier à partir de 21h à
21h à la salle de la tour de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et puis je sais
que cette pièce vous m'avez dit en tout
cas cette pièce allait partir pour le
Off d'Avignon normalement en 2016
comment nous avons les réponses merci
beaucoup et il se Vigan d'être venu sur
le plateau de kiosque merci à vous allez
une autre date de spectacle que je vous
propose cette fois pour le jeune public
c'est à partir de 8 ans c'est vendredi
soir à partir de 20h à l'estaminet de
manie elle est à Meaux 20 000 lieues
sous les mers sur un texte évidemment
original de Jules Verne la compagnie
imaginaire théâtre propose un spectacle
entre compte fantastique et théâtre
d'objets tarifs à partir de 5 euros
extrait
S
les Pokémon crew était à la Merise de
Trappes la danse de
la compagnie de danse hip-hop ça y est
je retrouve mes mots lyonnaise a
présenté un silence on tourne nous les
avons rencontrés
de la danse hip-hop présente dans le
cinéma des années 30 difficile à
imaginer pourtant c'est un film de 1928
qui a inspiré la compagnie Pokémon crew
on voyait une personne tourner sur la
tête et ça m'a vachement interpellé
parce que on se posait la question d'où
venait ce mouvement d'où il a été créé
une vidéo je pense qu'il y avait tout le
monde d'accord en expliquant que la
danse hip hop c'est beaucoup inspiré de
toutes les danses et surtout de ces
années-là année 20 et 30 ou les comédies
musicales arrivaient en force
silence on tourne c'est l'histoire d'un
making of qui n'a jamais rêvé de voir ce
qu'il se passe derrière une caméra les
Pokémon crew en proposent leur vision on
a imaginé un temps pendant le tournage
d'un film
donc ça on laisse le spectateur imaginer
à sa manière mais nous par exemple on a
imaginé une pause la pose du par exemple
la pose du comédien après avoir tourné
toute la journée on a imaginé le temps
on a essayé de
prendre la place du travelling de moi de
création 5 tableaux et 9 danseurs pour
un savoureux mélange de performance
d'humour et de poésie
les Pokémon crew c'est aussi une
histoire de rue de Battle à ce jour la
compagnie est double championne du monde
championne d'Europe et double championne
de France et entre les compétitions et
la scène c'est parfois le grand écart
c'est différent c'est pas qu'on peut
compliquer ces différents parce que
c'est un autre cadre
là il y a un espace à respecter
une écriture chorégraphique une
présence scénique il y a des comptes à
respecter dans ce que la compétition
c'est un peu freestyle comme on dit
c'est rentre tu fais ton passage comme
tu sens avec ton esprit et nous
justement on a envie d'emmener cette
énergie là de la compétition mais sur
scène cadrée
et pourtant tellement fou une chose est
sûre après tout ça on ne regardera plus
un film de la même manière
et puis maintenant quelques dates à
retenir dans l'agenda musique l'élysie
en amorella célèbre opéra de denisetti
sera donné vendredi 16 et samedi 17
janvier au Théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines
une version concert orchestrée par David
dexterne et les chanteurs et musiciens
de l'Opéra Foucault tarif à partir de 6
euros 50 et je propose maintenant un
extrait d'un désert les plus connu on a
fourniva la crime
alors vous n'êtes pas peut-être des
chanteurs d'opéra vous êtes peut-être
tout simplement des chanteurs un karaoké
vous est proposé par deux passionnés ce
sera samedi à 15h à la médiathèque à
thanol Anatole France pardon de Trappes
l'entrée et Liban et puis du jazz pour
finir cette agenda avec Cécile maclorin
Salvan samedi soir ou prisme Élancourt
tarif à partir de 16 euros une chanceuse
franco-américaine année en 89 en Floride
et qui a été lauréate en 2010 du premier
prix du Concours international de jazz
vocal tell of news Monk elle débute le
piano à 5 ans le jazz vocal et lyrique à
8 ans elle étudie au conservatoire de
musique d'Aix-en-Provence et je vous
propose un extrait c'est juste
vocalement à tomber écoutez
il y a cette fille en
vrai
cette semaine pour sa chronique Nicolas
Gervais nous entraîne dans un univers de
marionnettes en compagnie de Sylvain
Maurice et de ses sorcières mais qui
tire les fils
directeur du Centre dramatique national
de Sartrouville il adapte le texte de
Roald Dahl les sorcières en marionnettes
dans un spectacle familial à voir le 24
janvier à la Merise à Trappes voici
Sylvain Maurice dans le kiosque
les sorcières
les sorcières qui font des tours de
bas au noir ce n'est pas très excitant
non pas celle des contes je te parle des
vraies sorcières
les vrais sorcières détestent les
enfants j'ai souhaité mettre en scène ce
texte parce que
quand je l'ai lu à mes enfants
ils ont été tellement enthousiastes que
je me suis dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose à faire quoi voilà en fait c'est
un sujet
grave quand même puisque ça ça parle de
l'histoire d'un garçon comme ça qui a
perdu ses parents
mais c'est traité sur un mode très
ludique très joyeux c'est très drôle
en même temps on a un peu peur
ce petit garçon va déjouer un complot
mondial de sorcières donc c'est des
aventures
il allait arriver des tas d'histoires
et puis les grandes personnes marchent
sur l'image
et l'étrange
sans même savoir que c'était un enfant
c'est un spectacle mais il n'y a que des
marionnettes il y en a beaucoup il y en
a une trentaine et c'est un spectacle on
voit pas les manipulateurs on voit pas
les gens qui manipulent les marionnettes
et en effet elles sont de différentes
tailles de différentes techniques c'est
un spectacle qui aussi est de la musique
en direct il y a quelque chose de très
très varié de très ludique
ons
avec tous ces bonbons gratuits
donc là la marionnette notamment on a
fait tout un travail esthétique autour
de l'arpentation de cette sorcière la
marionnette permet vraiment d'aller plus
loin dans l'art plantation du magique du
fantastique l'idée c'est que en fait
tout autour de nous il y a des sorcières
qui existent partout on ne le sait pas
là actuellement là autour de nous là
dans ce hall il y a des sorcières
peut-être si vous voulez voir le
spectacle vous saurez comment les
reconnaître on vous donnera tous les
trucs pour déjouer leur complot
du chocolat
des bons pays avec
toi
la marionnette c'est formidable parce
que ça oblige à beaucoup de disciplines
et de rigueur on est obligé beaucoup de
en permanence de travailler sur
un peu comme un danseur ou un musicien
là où un acteur va être davantage sur
des choses subjectives sur comment est
mon personnage comment je peux être dans
un psychologie à marianettis c'est à la
fois un acteur et en même temps
quelqu'un qui se dit bah tiens est-ce
que je suis bouger la main le rythme de
la main l'énergie est bonne est-ce que
comment je me positionne par rapport à
la lumière voilà donc en fait c'est tout
un travail technique et de ce point de
vue là oui c'est assez différent du
simple jeu d'acteur
mais c'est un spectacle familial qu'on
peut voir à n'importe quel âge chacun
suivant son âge peut
s'y intéresser les enfants ils vont
plutôt retenir peut-être
le côté aventure fantastique
avoir peur autour de la sorcière les
adultes qui vont voir que ça raconte
aussi quelque chose autour de la
transmission
ça aurait pu être pire je leur ai
échappé je suis encore en
vie et de même pour brune
ça sent la banane
et moi j'aime bien les bananes Roald
Dahl c'est un auteur génial parce que
c'est un auteur qui a énormément
d'humour et c'est un humour
digne de la grande tradition anglaise
quoi que nous on n'a pas tellement en
France où on rit de choses qui font peur
les sorcières un autre tour de magie
puisque nous allons nous téléporter tout
de suite sur le plateau du kiosque
disparition
et avant de nous quitter je vous propose
le coup de coeur d'un professionnel du
septième art ce soir Luc bocquand du
ciné 7 d'Élancourt
alors bonjour donc mon coup de coeur le
coup de coeur du ciné 7 cette semaine
c'est un film noir parce que nous aimons
les films noirs aussi des 7 un polar
même l'affaire SK1 donc ça raconte en
fait la traque du premier serial qui
leur français c'est un film de Frédéric
Tellier qui est très réussi qui est très
intense très nerveux avec un beau
casting puisque à l'affiche on a
Nathalie Baye Olivier Gourmet Raphaël
Personnaz voilà donc je vous encourage
après la french de Cédric Gimenez de
nouveau un polar français
depuis le début on tombe que sur des
suspects qui collent pas pour moi il y a
quelque chose qui demande à sortir
28 ans
possibles mais pas certain tu s'arrêtes
trois ans il recommence on travaille mal
tous on travaille mal quand génétique a
été baptisé SK1 serial killer numéro 1
c'est le premier tueur en série dont on
a l'empreinte génétique
puis aussi un deuxième petit coup de
cœur
pour une soirée qu'on organise avec une
association qui s'appelle la brise du
mammouth qui est qui a été monté par
deux jeunes élancourtois et mortasien et
on fait une soirée zombie donc vendredi
à partir de 21h et on projettera deux
films zombies 2 et de la mort et de la
mort voilà
bonne semaine à vous et puis gardez
l'esprit ouvert et curieux